Greek freaking transition
good job by the Hornets to get bet
except when I forgot one guy yeah you
created all that contact Cody just stood
his ground power dribble for land that's
blocked by antenna cool ball they have
to execute what their objectives are Lee
gets in this matches when you get those
three stars from the floor at the same
time and it results in a three-pointer
for defense Genzo play right here Eric
when Anthony Cooper has the ball up top
you see lots of different defenses lots
of bodies pathetic elbow gets it to
Henson Malik monk with the misfire and
tentacles ball rocked it you've got to
be kidding
and kg starts to break the fines hear me
laughing River Wow dangerous entry paths
and Teta comfo catches it ends coming in
the first quarter tempo as Cody on it I
took that was gonna be he got all the
way to the tip the in his lead it takes
you three years the line you come that
type of player so I'm not so rushed
I suppose and telescope boat working on
the rookie Bridget's done that's a lot
of people as his leg
[Applause]
[Music]
I think Yanis is going at bridges what
he's getting you since they're gonna
split that first wit and I'm too good so
there's the rookie he's just gonna back
him down like I figure strong with your
225 but you have no idea which way
Kimmel was going and Kim so quick to
love to get that type of collection this
year Rick freak working the gods nkg low
from Yanis keep your Chris no slouch up
top himself